gilles duceppe et le nouveau chef du
bloc québécois
un nouveau cycle politique commence et
l'heure est au rassemblement de toutes
les forces indépendantistes l'espèce de
convergence entre ces événements un
mouvement qui tend vers leur
rassemblement des forces
indépendantistes nous autres les devis
c'est pas le bloc les miss et arpin faut
être vraiment mal pris à l'effet pour le
bloc québécois doit aller chercher
monsieur duceppe c'est certain que les
québécois vont devoir tout un choix
rendu aux prochaines élections alors on
peut dire que c'est la première surprise
de cette campagne électorale qui
s'amorce ce retour de gilles duceppe à
la tête du bloc québécois
on a parlé de l'effet pierre karl
péladeau quel sera l'effet du cep sur le
mouvement souverainiste et sur les
élections
tasha michel daniel bonsoir alors
comment est ce que l'arrivée de gilles
duceppe va changer la donne ça va
brasser quand même les cartes
michel oui certainement écouté jusqu'à
avant-hier
finalement le scénario le plus plausible
était la disparition pure et simple du
dock à la prochaine élection avec mario
beaulieu honnêtement ça allait nulle
part maintenant avec monsieur duceppe
on est j'imagine assez certain d'aller
au moins chercher tous ceux qui ont
déserté le bloc depuis le
depuis l'arrivée de monsieur beaulieu et
fort probablement aussi de revenir à
tout le moins au niveau de 2011 ce qui
était pas suffisant pour le vu que ça a
donné quoi cinq sièges
mais on peut facilement imaginer qu'on
remonte à des niveaux de 25 ans 25 et 30
pour ça et là on arrive dans ce qu'on
appelle la zone payante et dans delta iv
on peut très bien imaginer que le bloc
retrouve un peut-être 25 sièges alors
c'est une très bonne nouvelle pour le
blanc c'est d'accord avec ça daniel oui
absolument écouter si vous me demandez
est-ce que ce soir le bloc québécois est
en meilleure position qu'a semaine
dernière sans aucun doute jean duceppe
voulez mais vous ne l'aimez pas mais
c'est un politicien aguerri il sait
comment jouer le jeu de politique
il sait comment faire un discours ici
comment soulever une foule si aussi
comment gagne un débat télévisé c'est
pas c'est pas c'est pas inutile sauf que
on l'a vu et michel ladi un peu on l'a
vu aujourd'hui avec la csn peu plus tôt
avec la ftq des deux grandes centrales
syndicales au québec disent il faut
arrêter d'être si wallraff eux à la
prochaine élection
ici pour cela il faut voter démocrate
libéral votants les eaux des mois 4 et
ou libérale oui je duceppe change la
donne mais rien est acquis
tasha comment est-ce que ça a été perçu
ce retour à sa cause une surprise dans
le reste du canada
ces dernières sur le radar et beaucoup
de gens se disent mais pourquoi et
pourquoi mais c'est du sept voudrais
revenir après la défaite cuisante qui
l'a eu et c'est une question à poser
c'est sûr qu'il y avait un sondage qui
démontrait que le score du bloc serait
beaucoup mieux sur lui et je pense je
suis d'accord avec michel et danièle que
c'est mieux aujourd'hui que c'était la
semaine passée mais quand même je suis
d'accord avec monsieur moquer et
beaucoup de canadiens aussi parce que
c'est c'est come back de futures comme
il le dit et c'est quelque chose qui est
déjà été vécue sous monsieur duceppe
c'est une chose de reprendre un parti
qui a été fait sous quelqu'un d'autre
mais quand c'est le parti qui a été fait
sous toit
c'est quelque chose très très différents
bon en 2011 quand même le vote de
protestation ils s'étaient déplacés du
bloc vers le npd mais le personne je
crois penser que le npd pourrait gagner
or là quand même le npd a une chance de
l'emporter vous en parler
michel daniel mais ça change quand même
un peu les choses non shell oui oui ça
change en particulier depuis la victoire
du npd en alberta la possibilité d'un
gouvernement d'un nouveau crac est très
réel et ce qui apparaît c'est pas du
tout en 2011
maintenant est ce que par exemple
l'argument de monsieur de monsieur
duceppe c'est à dire écoutez on a vu ce
que ça donnait en 2011
on a fait élire 50 quelques députés ils
savent à empêcher les conservateurs
d'être majoritaires maintenant j'ai
l'impression mois qu' il ya beaucoup de
gens qui vont prendre la chance de re
voter npd qui tu m'as dit souverainiste
qui est assez bon ben on réglera la
question de la souveraineté au québec
mais que le plus urgent c'est de se
débarrasser le défi de gilles duceppe
s'est il utile lui même c'est de
rassembler les forces indépendantistes
ya quoi 25 % des québécois qui ont voté
pour le pq la dernière fois quand on
leur pose la question sur un éventuel
référendum de huy tourne autour de 40%
si duceppe est capable de mobiliser 25 %
de la population
il est il est dans la partie et peut
faire des gains et peut faire des gains
importants sauf que il va falloir pour
cela que les que les indépendantistes
les souverainistes cesse de faire de
beaux discours et qu'ils s'impliquent
dans cette campagne aux côtés de gilles
duceppe il a besoin désespérément de
trouver des candidats prestigieux il y
en a pas pour l'instant j'ai besoin de
trouver de l'argent
j'ai besoin de mettre sur pied
l'organisation en très peu de temps il
va falloir que les gros canons du
véhicule pierre karl péladeau en tête à
celle se dire oui oui c'est bon le black
et qu'il aille sur le terrain avec
gilles duceppe sinon ça ne marchera pas
alors donc le npd qui va en souffrir le
plus probablement mais qu'est ce que ça
veut dire pour justin trudeau tâche à un
c'est une bonne chose pour lui écoute ça
divise le vote clairement si le bloc et
là ça va diminuer le vote potentiels de
l'aisne [ __ ] ce qui permettrait aux
libéraux peut-être de récolter plus de
sièges et monsieur trudeau a déjà dit
suite aux revenus des métiers du cirque
que bon ça va susciter le doute le débat
sur le fédéralisme qui est un débat
important à faire et qui bénéficie aux
libéraux mais aussi la possibilité jëf
réfléchir ça que monsieur ans après
aussi peu en profiter parce qu'il peut
sortir le spectre d'une coalition non
seulement aux socialistes mais
souverainiste
ce qu'il a fait en 2011 il a dit à
possibilité d'une coalition avec les
souverainistes et dangereux pour le
canada alors peut-être ça va lui aidé
aussi monsieur à peu certains contenta
chasse ils sortent ou aux minoritaires
et que le bloc que de se taire pendant
quelques mois ou tatem une année ou deux
alors ça joue dans les deux sens et joue
partout oui ça le ferait après visé
plusieurs scénarios possibles venons à
l'impact sur le mouvement souveraines et
sur le mouvement souverainiste
michel c'est quand même un duo
particulier non pkp gilles duceppe
oui c'est assez particulier l'ancien
syndicaliste qui veut aller main dans la
main avec la voix du local certains vous
aimez ce soir en coupe
un couple assez bizarre mais je pense
que monsieur péladeau et monsieur doucet
comprennent parfaitement que le bloc on
doit soutenir le bloc pour ne pas nuire
à l'ensemble du mouvement souverainiste
maintenant qu'on le veuille ou non le
bloc c'est un espèce de baromètre
quand le bloc tombe bas il ya tout un
aspect de mouvement de déprime en si bon
la souveraineté tombe alors le pq est
condamné a appuyé me sauver je pense que
malgré les larges antécédents respectifs
le courant vaut mieux passer avec
monsieur duceppe qu'avec monsieur
beaulieu on l'a vu au tout début
la réaction de monsieur péladeau a vers
le bloc qui était de blocs de mario
beaulieu c'était ni plus ni moins que
cette histoire c'est fini là je pense
que l'attitude vont être différentes et
que l'appui que le pq veut donner au
bloc doit être nettement meilleur que ce
qu'il aurait été avec monsieur beaulieu
mais il ya le danger quand même si c'est
le blog que ne revient pas d'une façon
et mêmes
respectez ça va démontrer que peut-être
ce qu'on a vécu au père ciel récemment
scellé fait tiquer café l'effet du
revenu du mouvement souverainiste n'est
vraiment pas là c'est pour ça que le pq
va s'engager fortement derrière le bloc
4 milliards ce moment un espèce de
d'ébullition au parti québécois dans la
foulée de l'élection de pierre karl
péladeau c'est un nouveau chef
les militants sont très confiants sont
contents de voir là il ya eu jacques
parizeau son décès ça a suscité une très
grande réflexion chez les souverainistes
qui se disent comme monsieur parizeau
écouter ci lui il ya cru jusqu'au bout
pourquoi nous on y croirait pas mais il
ya un travail à faire il est énorme mais
celle là dit il va falloir que tout ce
monde se serre la main parce que dans
delta iv ils peuvent gagner 25 côté mais
peuvent en gagner sur mars avec aussi
bon alors passons maintenant à un autre
sujet c'est l'impasse sur l'avenir du
sénat faut-il leurs efforts mais faut-il
abolir la question se pose de plus en
plus avec bien sûr le scandale des
dépenses du sénateur t'achète à certains
qui parlent même maintenant vain de
faire un référendum sur cette question
oui parce que je pense c'est la seule
façon de vraiment redémarrer le débat de
façon productive parce qu'on sait tous
que la cour suprême a statué que ça
passe par les provinces
la réforme ou l'abolition larifou la
réforme c'est une boîte de pandore ça
ouvre tout la possibilité que le québec
autres provinces aussi ramènerait
d'autres choses sur la table mais
l'abolition on pourrait mettre la
question à la population très clair et
net
oui ou non ce statu quo ou évolution
qu'est ce que vous voulez si la
population voterai pour l'abolition
légalement il n'y a pas d'effet mais ça
provoquerait pour les premiers ministres
des provinces la possibilité de dire oui
on va l'abolir parce que le peuple le
veut ce sera plus un obstacle à
l'évolution est peut-être on y
arriverait mais c'est pas si simple
daniel parce que ça risque en tout cas
d'être un enjeu électoral assez
important à la prochaine campagne
ben si je t'ai l'élu démocrate bloquiste
ou libérale je rappellerai sens inverse
qui veulent un peu qu'il a nommé
d'excellents sénateurs qui se trouve
aujourd'hui entre les mains de la grc
sauf que sauf que le débat fonds doit
aller au delà de ça oui au référendum ce
serait très bon ça forcerait la main des
provinces
moi je serai le référendum sur
l'abolition ou là
forme parce que le sedj cours vous
voulez garder ses notes tel qu'il est
aujourd'hui je pense pas que beaucoup de
canadiens qui soit ça donc donc le
référendum comme on a fait aux états
unis sur ces questions est ce que
monsieur un peu auraient courage de le
faire ce serait une fort bonne idée as
que est-ce qu'on doit avoir par cissé
l'option réforme du sénat qui
l'emportent d'ouvrir la constitution à
chaque fois qu'on d'ouvrir la
constitution tout le monde a l'air de
penser que c'est la fin du monde est ce
que est ce qu'on se rende and jusqu'à la
fin des temps
ce que je veux moi 6 2 pour couvrir ces
débats-là au jour le jour mais de façon
plus fondamentale est-ce que le canada
se condamne à l'immobilisme jusqu'à la
fin de ses jours parce que y'a peur que
y ait trop de demandes est ce qu un
scandale la fiv avec la magie avec la
monarchie avec le sénat tel qu'il est
parce qu'on a peur de faire deux de
négocier me semble que nos chefs nous et
les gens devraient avoir un peu plus de
colonne vertébrale non même si les
brouillards michel a dit qu'ils étaient
opposés à l'abolition qu'il ne sera et
que le québec le sera toujours
alors ouais ce qui lui tient tant à se
saigner c'est traditionnellement de
québec veut s'assurer puis ça a été la
poupe la position d'un départ que le
sénat soit un espèce de contrepoids à sa
perte de poids relatif à la chambre des
communes alors il ya toutes sortes de
tentatives dans le passé
le livre beige sur à une par exemple on
voulait de l'abolir mais le remplacer
par une chambre des provinces où le
québec se verrait garantir 25% des des
membres alors il ya toujours cette
préoccupation là mais le scénario du
référendum ça a l'air très séduisant
comme ça c'est je me souviens que maxime
bernier en avait fait la proposition est
une coque d'année à ce moment là il y
avait eu un sondage au québec et 52 %
des québécois état pour l'abolition mais
imaginez on voit monsieur couillard et
et qu'on dit incapable référendaire que
le gouvernement et compte peut-être le
pq serait content peut-être que tous les
partis de l'assemblée nationale serait
contre l'abolition et là on aurait un
résultat ou le reste du canada devait
abolir le sénat mais le quai bellevue le
maintenir au québec pas parce qu'on aime
le sénat mais parce qu'on veut pas
perdre cette arme ou d'équilibrage ou de
marchandage dans une négociation
éventuelle
alors ça a l'air bien beau comme ça mais
c'est ça peut être extrêmement
le diable est dans les détails et sans
doute un gros ce qu'il faudrait pas le
remplacer de toute façon par quelque
chose c'est non il est arrivé je j'ai eu
un exemple que je voyais un petit peu
plus tôt aujourd'hui en nouvelle zélande
on abolit on n'a pas remplacé mais ça a
mené à la longue un changement dans le
mode de scrutin parce qu'on s'est rendu
compte que les régions étaient pas
suffisamment représentés on a introduit
la proportionnelle et loyer n'est toutes
sortes de petits partis régionaux
justement pour combler l'absence du
sénat alors d'une manière ou d'une autre
il va falloir dans un pays aussi vaste
que le canada que les régions les
provinces en l'occurrence trouve le
moyen de s'exprimer dans le parlement
central mais il ya d'autres façons aussi
si on voulait donner plus de deux
commissions comités parlementaires le
travail qui est fait présentement par le
seigneur beaucoup de comités
il ya plein de députés qui aimeraient
avoir un plus grand rôle dans la chambre
des communes
pourquoi pas augmenter la responsabilité
c'est pas l'expression des provinces là
ça serait simplement des députés
fédéraux qui aurait plus de
responsabilités voilà l'idéal si tu ne
vas l'idéal c'est une réforme mais qui
dit réformes sérieuses en profondeur du
sel a dit aussi que ces gens là si les
sénateurs sont élus il faut leur donner
des pouvoirs
ce docu des marionnettes qui font ce que
le parti à la chambre des communes leur
demain donc il faut lui donner des
pouvoirs
cc c'est compliqué c'est compliqué mais
un référendum ce serait le fun cheikh
michel un peu paumé se serait de toute
façon négociations constitutionnelles
mais bon un jour peut-être pas que le
sujet
allez vous allumez hauteur mais ça fait
plaisir j'avais annoncé que c'est notre
dernière table ronde on vous aime
tellement peut pas se passer de vous
alors en voudront se retrouve la semaine
prochaine pour un nouveau travail
merci beaucoup à vous trois voire